c'est la plus grande centrale nucléaire
d'Europe zapporija dans le sud de
l'Ukraine est toujours sous contrôle des
forces russes et le restera sur le
porte-parole du Kremlin hier pourtant le
Président de l'opérateur ukrainien ergo
atome évoqué des signes suggérons à un
retrait prochain des forces russes on
fait le point avec Gulliver crack à Kiev
pour France 24
pour le moment la centrale des
aporisiens est toujours occupé par les
forces russes qui se servent d'ailleurs
de position située non loin de cette
centrale pour tirer des obus sur la
ville ukrainienne notamment de nicopole
et d'autres villages autour de nicopôle
c'est juste de l'autre côté du fleuve et
c'était le cas encore hier ou 30 au but
ce sont abattus sur la ville et ses
environs sont toutefois faire de
victimes selon les autorités locales les
rustices que ces rumeurs comme quoi elle
se préparé à partir sont complètement
infondées pétrotine le président des
nerdouatum c'était fondé sur des
observations que lui avait été reliées
par par ses contacts sur place comme
quoi les Russes semblaient à pied le
site et prendre ce qu'il pouvait ces
petro-cottines qu'il a interprété comme
une signe comme quoi il se préparerait
peut-être à partir Michael au podoléac
un conseiller du président ukrainien
volodi mirzelinski a dit que lui aussi
pens que les grises partiraient du fait
des avancées prévisibles de l'armée
ukrainienne dans la région beaucoup
d'ukrainien Satan de ce qu'il y ait une
nouvelle contrefontive ukrainien dont la
région des aporisa mais ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui est vraiment en cours
pour le moment ce qui est en cours cela
on le sait ce sont des négociations
entre
l'agence internationale pour l'énergie
atomique et son président Raphaël grossi
avec les autorités ukrainiennes et
russes Raphaël grossi à maintes reprises
a appelé à la création d'une zone de
militarisée autour de la centrale de
zaporigia pour sécuriser le site maison
c'est vraiment pas quelle carte il a aux
mains pour essayer de convaincre les
Russes de partir en tout cas
publiquement ils ne veulent pas du tout
parler à ton éventuel retrait